hundreds have already arrived and
thousands more are on the way it will be
one of the biggest ceremonial events
ever seen on The Streets of London and
the largest Security operation we've got
you know more than 300 VIPs Prime
Ministers presidents royalty from across
the Globe coming to our city will have
hundreds of thousands of people along
the ceremonial procession route and the
job of the police site is a really hard
one to keep us safe to keep us secure
but to let everyone to have a good time
and I'm really confident the preparation
the planning has been fantastic and
exemplary as you can see behind me some
of the hard-working police taken well
deserved break more than a million
people are expected to come to these
streets to celebrate the coronation and
most of them will be peaceful but with
crowds of this size just one incident
could have a huge impact
to ensure iron Cloud protection on the
king's big day more than 11 000 officers
have been deployed aided by new
legislation which carries up to a year
in jail for anyone tempted to cause
disruption
our assessments of the Tipping Point to
say this protest has gone beyond the
reasonable inter being disruptive and
therefore we're going to intervene it's
a much lower tolerance than it might be
on a normal day that's what this is
about
but the lower tolerance approach seems
hard to Define I'm not going to go into
every individual case because it depends
on what's exactly on the ground that day
but if if that is going to fundamentally
obstruct the enjoyment and celebration
for a significant number of people
that's disrupting the events and that
would probably tip us into action
concerning for activists whose main
tactics involve civil disruption which
on Saturday could land them in jail what
is the right time in the right place you
know whenever they say this it's always
why don't you go to the pavement where
nobody can see you and do your little
protest but this is absolutely the right
time look at how many people are here in
Parliament this is the ideal opportunity
police have worked with activists to
provide a space where they can have
their say but the new laws mean they can
protest but not disrupt a controversial
measure the police have to get right as
it's being tested on the day the world
will be watching Shimon Freeman Powell
Sky News